and why'd the number of new cases per
day is flattening substantially
suggesting that we are near the peak and
our comprehensive strategy is working
overtime our guidelines to slow the
spread or decreasing the rate of new
cases vary substantially and will result
in fewer hospital admissions and we're
seeing that it's incredible I think with
with no exceptions it's looking like
it's lower and again that's because of
the people doing what they had to do
great people and and working with
elected representatives and and the
doctors the nurses and everybody I mean
just everybody everybody so-so
has been so amazing I was told this
morning again please mention all of
those people working in to the grocery
stores and it's true the checkouts and
the clerks and the people that are
really and a number of those people have
become infected so we want to thank them
and a shout out to them with the
tireless devotion of American doctors
and nurses and all of the medical people
we've kept our fatality rate very very
low compared to other countries my
administration is closely monitoring the
data and the viruses impact on our
cherished african-american communities
because they've been hit hard and the
Surgeon General will be sharing more
that information right after we're
finished here he'll be coming up and
saying exactly what's happening because
it's really it's very troublesome I will
tell you that I'd also like to provide
clarity on the important point for many
Americans on elective surgeries while
we've asked hospitals to cancel
surgeries and procedures that do not
take place at this time just not to do
them now the choice to delay any
treatment still remains between the
patient and their doctor
we're not advising Americans to postpone
medical treatment that their doctor
believes should occur now so it's
different kinds of surgery obviously
but we're really getting to the point
where you can start to think about doing
that surgery if necessary pretty soon I
think pretty soon yesterday I directed
Secretary of Agriculture Sonny to
predict sonny perdue to expedite aid to
American farmers and secretary do we'll
be using all of the tools at his
disposal to develop a program and very
quickly of at least 16 billion dollars
to provide relief for farmers ranchers
and producers impacted by the corona
virus in this time of crisis we must
keep our supply chains moving from the
beginning right from beginning to end
and we're committed to supporting the
amazing men and women who produce supply
I did last night a statement on social
media and I said I have directed
secretary sonny perdue to expedite help
to our farmers especially to the smaller
farmers who are very very badly hurting
right now
I expect secretary Perdue to use all of
the funds and authorities at his
disposal to make sure that our food
supply is stable and safe and our great
farmers are prosperous and continue to
be prosperous we're working very hard to
make sure our food supply chain is sound
and plentiful but we all know that that
begins with our farmers cattlemen
ranchers and producers so we're going to
be working with these small farmers the
big farmers the cattlemen the ranchers
all of the producers we're going to take
care of them we're working with them
right now we have a lot of money that
was put there through our use of tariffs
and other means and we're gonna help out
our farmers and I don't think I'll tell
you I've been helping our farmers for a
couple of years because they were
targeted as you know by China and others
and I think they're very grateful to
what for what we've done on the medical
front the FDA FDA has issued 47
emergency use authorization x' for
advancements and testing new ventilator
designs and
Asians and personal protective equipment
and experimental medicines and dr.
Hahn's going to be talking about that
we've cut through the red tape to give
doctors and patients unprecedented
freedom to make their own healthcare
decisions
granting access to potential therapies
and drugs since Monday we've deployed
two major shipments of
hydroxychloroquine from our national
stockpile it's going to various cities
and we are also disposing and getting as
quickly as we can portions of it to the
Department of Veterans Affairs and the
Department of Defense and speaking of
the Department of Defense they're going
to be sending us ten million n95 masks
that they had and we're in great shape
and every way we're in great shape with
ventilators we're in great shape with
protective clothing we have additional
plane loads coming in but we're not
getting any calls from governor's at
this moment I can speak I think for vice
president pence will be talking in a
little while we're getting we're getting
very few calls from from governor's or
anybody else needing anything they're in
great shape for this surge that's coming
in certain areas in particular and
that's a good job you've done a great
job in that Mike really a great job I
appreciate it the whole country
appreciates it
more than 2-million coronavirus tests
have now been completed and we're
conducting approximately 100,000 more
every day we're also working to bring
blood based sri ology tests to the
market as quickly as possible so that
Americans can determine whether or not
they have already had the virus and
potentially have immunity
they have immunity of they've had the
virus a lot of them don't even know if
they've had it sometimes it's brutal you
see the Prime Minister seems to be doing
well now I hope he had a rough go of it
and and still is but he's doing better
and then some people don't even know
they had it it could be sniffles it
could be they don't feel perfect but
they've had it and they're they're the
lucky ones
the NIH CDC and FDA are currently
validating these antibody tests to
ensure that they are accurate and
they're doing that at breakneck speed I
think we can say that doctor we're gonna
get them approved very quickly dr.
Hahn's when validated we're confident
that the production will scale up to
tens of millions of tests very quickly
we're leading the world now in testing
by far and we're going to keep it that
way
other countries are coming to us and
they're wanting to know about our tests
and can they buy the tests and can they
do whatever they have to do to get the
tests and we're going to make that very
soon we'll be in a position to make that
possible because it's important for them
to have it and we're gonna have an
announcement on the World Health
Organization sometime next week as you
know we give them approximately five
hundred million dollars a year and we're
gonna be talking about that subject next
week we'll have a lot to say about it
we'll hold it every American should be
proud of what our country is achieved in
just a short period of time the US
military has deployed
thousands of personnel to build 23
temporary hospitals with more than
16,000 beds and we have the potential to
build them anymore if we needed them
we're all ready to go but I don't think
we're gonna need them which is great
great news and we built those hospitals
in 12 states and the District of
Columbia using the defense production
act and we used it like a hammer a lot
of the media said oh we weren't using
that we used it like a hammer to a point
where all we had to do is say the words
and everybody gave us Mac's and and
they've done a good job they really have
done a good job with few exceptions and
we've harnessed the full power of
American industry to produce ventilators
and other essential supplies right now
we're making thousands of ventilators
many of which we won't need but we'll
use them in our stockpile and we'll
build that up we'll also help build up
the stockpiles which they should have
had in the States and so we're working
with governor's on that and we'll
so help other countries there are
countries that are calling us for help
they need ventilators and there are no
position to build ventilators we are we
have Ford and General Motors and many
many companies are building ventilators
so we're going to be helping at a not
too distant point we're going to be
helping quite a few of the countries now
we've launched project air bridge to
deliver nearly 300 million pieces of
personal protective equipment from and
around the globe
we're also shipping out 60 sterilization
systems to 10 different cities that can
each sterilize up to 80,000 masks each
day and I'm even hearing it can go up to
120 thousand masks a day certain
equipment with certain editions it's a
company in Ohio that makes it a great
company great I hear it's a great
product works very well I asked that
question I said how come we have to buy
so many mess why can't we sterilize the
masks that are being used and the answer
was you can in this case they say up to
20 times so we can take a mask certain
types of masks the n95 in particular we
can sterilize them make them very clean
up to 20 times that's a great thing in
addition we passed the largest emergency
economic relief package in American
history to save the US economy and
protect the American worker as you know
this past week which was four active
days on the stock market Good Friday
today is not is not included the markets
are closed in four days we had the
biggest market increased stock market
increase that we've had in 50 years that
tells you that there's a pent-up demand
that tells you they want to get back
there's something good going to happen I
really believe that there's something
very good going to happen we have to get
back so think of it in this horrible
period this horrible dark period where
this this monster came and and worked
it's horrible horrible spell over the
world 184 countries as of this morning
hundred and eighty four countries
we've done well and I guess the market
thinks we've done well because we had
the biggest stock market increase
without one day we're talking four days
instead of five that we've had in 50
years 50 years think of that more than
50 years actually in short the American
people have launched the greatest
mobilization of our society since World
War two deploying every scientific
governmental medical and military
resource to defeat the virus so I want
to just start then with we're gonna
answer questions later we'll have time
if we have a lot of time today a lot of
people are off as they should be good
Friday but so I'll stick around we'll
answer questions later I want to start
with deborah birx please dr. Burks and
you can go over some of the numbers we
just looked at and that'd be great thank
you very much different
thank you for outlining how well we are
doing in a series of metro areas what
also has been encouraging for those of
you are watching epidemic curves every
day and I'm sure you are and lot
watching them in log phase because
that's how Abedini ologist like to look
at their curves you can see for the
first time that in the United States
we're starting to level on the
logarithmic phase like Italy did about a
week ago
and so this gives us great heart that
only in specific places but we're
starting to see that change obviously a
lot of that is driven by the improvement
in New York City
remember for a long time they were over
50% of our cases and 50% of our new
cases that is dramatically changed
because of the impact of what the
citizens of New York and New Jersey and
across Connecticut and now Rhode Island
are doing to really change the course of
this pandemic and really change the
trajectory of new cases we're seeing
that what many states and metro areas
were experienced as twofold and four
fold four fold increases that went to
two fold that now those are going to
eight days between the doubling rate
watching this every day gives us hope
across these metro areas
from New York and New Jersey and all
through Denver and of course through New
Orleans we still see cases occurring in
the Boston area and in Chicago but their
rate of increase seems to be stabilizing
and we really want to call out the work
of the mayors of Baltimore and the
district and Philadelphia who have
really brought all of their health
health experts together and working with
their communities are starting to really
change the curves in those areas what
we're seeing is we're united in social
distancing and that's been very
encouraging to all of us and it should
be encouraging to the health care
providers that are on the front line
many of which are serving our Americans
with such dignity and respect and
ensuring that everybody gets optimal
care and as the president noted our
mortality in the United States is
significantly less than many of the
other countries when you correct them
for our population and that is really
solely the work of our health our
frontline health care providers and so
working with you can really hopefully
you get the theme today that we are
incredibly proud of our public health
leaders at the city level at the state
level at the federal level who are
working together to really change the
course of this pandemic working with
their citizens and their communities to
make these changes and the American
public who has really taken all of this
to heart and stayed home I know last
week we really asked a lot of people in
the Washington and Baltimore area to
consolidate not go out frequently to
grocery stores or pharmacies you can
really see that that's having a huge
impact so it's really about the
encouraging signs that we see but as
encouraging as they are we have not
reached the peak and so every day we
need to continue to do what we did
yesterday and the week before and the
week before that because that's what in
the end is going to take us up across
the peak and down the other side we
continue to really applaud the work of
California and Washington State in
Oregon we're learning from all three of
those states
from their public health officials about
how they were able to keep the virus
from ever becoming logarithmic and I
think that's an important lesson for all
of us on how they did that what the
timing was in case we ever have to face
this issue in the future Thank You mr.
president thank you very much mr.
president
so again just keeping on the theme that
dr. Burks had had mentioned this is the
end of the week that famous week that we
spoke about last weekend in which we
what actually was predicted to happen
happened was starting to see the
leveling off in there coming down that
dr. Burks had mentioned but it's
important to remember that this is not
the time to feel that since we have made
such important advance in the sense of
success of the mitigation that we need
to be pulling back at all I was actually
hearkened by the fact that we've been
talking about the New York New Jersey
New Orleans and other areas where they
have really big spikes but there's other
parts of the country in the middle parts
of the country where their concern to
make sure they don't get those spikes
and I really want to salute the
governors of states throughout the
entire United States but particularly in
the central part of the country because
the the governor's after you see us in
these press conferences and I've had
calls over the last several days from
several of the governors you know from
Nebraska Iowa South Dakota Utah just
about an hour and a half ago I spoke
with the governors of Arkansas and
Wyoming who are really committed to make
sure that they don't get into the
situation where they're gonna have
spikes in their state and they're doing
the kinds of things that they don't get
recognized because people don't talk
about them much but we have a big
country we have 50 states and it's not
only the big cities so if we're gonna
pull out of this we're gonna pull out of
it in the big cities and we're gonna
pull out it in those areas that aren't
as densely populated and I just want to
give a shout out to them they're doing
an extraordinary job I was really
pleasantly se surprised because I
expected of this country but to hear
what they're doing and the commitment
that they're putting in to making sure
that we don't have the kinds of
situations that we've experienced
unfortunately
in other areas this is very important I
just want to close by one of the things
something I mentioned yesterday and the
day before that there are a lot of
candidate interventions that are going
into clinical trials for those of you
are interested in it I recommend you go
to clinical trials.gov and you'll see
the design of a clinical trial and you
see that many of them are the randomized
control trials that are the really gold
standard of how you find out whether
something really is safe and effective
and as the weeks and months said it'll
probably be months sometime in the
summer we'll start to see which are
working which are not and to focus on
those that are we developing and we'll
working I'll be happy to answer
questions later thank you Thank You mr.
president
the White House Task Force has been very
focused on increasing the supply of
personal protective equipment for our
great providers I was one of those
providers a few months ago and I can
tell you nothing is more important than
making sure they have what they need so
in order to increase the supply of n95
masks FDA has worked with industry and
has now authorized two companies who
will supply machines to sterilize in 595
masks
Admiral pull-up check and FEMA are
purchasing on behalf of US government 60
sterilization machines as mentioned by
the President and they will be
positioned around the country to
increase the amount of supply than 95
masks
each machine will be able to sterilize
80,000 95 masks and 95 mass per day and
we hope to actually increase that
further the vice president and the White
House Task Force challenged us yesterday
and we responded as a team FDA issued
revised guidance regarding the
laundering of gowns because gowns are
another issue in terms of supply that
we're looking forward on this is not
something that normally happens around
the country but issued this guidance
it's on our website now at FDA so
there's information about how hospitals
can do that to increase the supply we've
heard concerns watching the daily White
House briefing on the corona virus just
heard Anthony Fauci talking about the
importance of keeping up with the
downs not the time that we pull back on
this at all he said before that of
course Donald Trump was at the podium
saying that clear signs are aggressive
the aggressive strategy is working which
is saying saving countless lives he said
we had a number of 100,000 lives lost he
said but I think we will be
substantially under that number let's
bring in our White House correspondent
can be Huggett who's been listening in
Kimberly what did you make of what you
though yeah before we go to the main
topic about coronavirus which is of
course what this is is an update on the
task force briefing the president u.s.
president started out that briefing with
a bit of an update on another story
we've been following here on al Jazeera
and that of course is the issue of the
oversupply of oil in the sort of the
larger global oil production system and
he announced there that he seems to
believe that he has worked out a end to
the standoff that has existed between
Mexico and OPEC to cut their crude by
hundred thousand barrels a day and he
talked about why this was important to
the United States because he was
concerned about the loss of jobs in that
industry so a little bit of an update
from the US president there and it is
important to note because we did know
earlier that he had also had a phone
call with the Russian President Vladimir
Putin where they talked about stability
in the global market so it's clear that
in addition to coronavirus this is one
of the other issues that the US
president has been working on in the
last few hours now turning to
coronavirus the US president still very
eager to tout what he sees as some of
the successes that have taken place in
the United States in the face of what
continued to be persistent criticisms
about his response in the United States
to the spread of coronavirus that he is
highlighting well he doesn't see it as a
positive headline by any means when
you're talking about the number of
deaths in the United States but the
number now downgraded from that initial
200,000 to even two million that was
first projected now looking in the range
of 60,000 he also talked about some of
the positive signs that are being seen
as a result of data with regard to some
of those hot spots New Orleans the city
of New Orleans
the Americans South as well as Detroit
Michigan in the north of the country
near the Canadian border and also
talking about that there seems to be
this flattening of the curve and you
heard that from some of the public
health officials as well that these are
very encouraging signs the US president
talking about this how do we know that
this is occurring in terms of that curve
and we talked about in charts and the
peak the flattening of it being the
reduction in fewer hospital admissions
showing that those guidelines that were
put in place till April 30th encouraging
people to stay home seems to be working
and that is something that's being
echoed by those public health officials
there but at the same time they're
cautioning as we go into a holiday
weekend here in the United States don't
change your behaviors because well it's
working
if those behaviors change two weeks from
now there could be a new spike and this
is what they're really worried about so
the guidance again stay home don't go
out unless absolutely necessary because
lives depend on it
right president Trump also talking about
whao actually referring to a an
announcement that will be made next week
reference at the 500 million dollars a
year that the US government gives to the
division yeah and I wanted to
double-check a little bit something the
proof certain tell me in my ear as we're
talking here and believe I'm going to
throw to an earlier soundbite where we
were listening to the World Health
Organization chief talking there and let
me set this up a little bit for you the
u.s. president there was talking about
an announcement that is imminent coming
from his side next week and of course
we've had this tit-for-tat back and
forth between the World Health
Organization and Donald Trump and he has
throughout this week reiterated that he
believes that the World Health
Organization has not delivered in terms
of outcomes that it was too slow to
declare a global health emergency so he
has been saying and threatening that he
is going to cut funding now we're not
entirely clear if that's what the
announcement will be we do know that the
United States is one of the largest
donor
but while not naming the president US
president directly the chief of the
World Health Organization has two
occasions this week been briefing where
he's spoken directly to Donald Trump's
challenges saying it is incumbent on g20
nations of which of course the United
States is one to make sure that the
other nations around the world about 30
percent are short on personal protective
equipment something he finds alarming
and that he feels that all of these sort
of wealthier nations like the United
States have a responsibility to address
take a listen to what dr. Tedder's had
to say earlier we're particularly
concerned by the large number of
infections reported among health workers
in some countries there are reports of
up to ten percent of health workers
being infected this is an alarming trend
when health workers are at risk we are
all at risk now in terms of
fact-checking one fact that did strike
me the US president talking about there
is that he said that the United States
in terms of contributions to the World
Health Organization that in fact he said
something about 500 million dollars a
year that that was the u.s. contribution
now we did some fact-checking here at
al-jazeera in the last couple of days
and that is not entirely true from the
numbers that we can see in fact Congress
for this fiscal year the US Congress
pledged 122 million to the World Health
Organization Donald Trump has proposed
58 million for the next fiscal year it's
unlikely Congress would allow the cut to
be that significant so we'll have to
watch very carefully for this imminent
announcement next week on the World
Health Organization the u.s. again
Donald Trump saying that he doesn't
believe it has delivered on outcomes and
it was slow to declare global emergency
with regard to coronavirus and now
threatening to cut aid something that
the World Health Organization says it
would certainly have a tremendously
detrimental impact given the global
health challenge it now faces and the
president also talking about deploying
two major shipments of the drug the
malaria drug
Roxi chloroquine and that's a drug of
which there has been some controversy
hasn't there yeah there's been a lot of
controversy regarding this mainly the
biggest controversy has come from the
fact that Donald Trump has no medical
background whatsoever but continues to
tout its benefits now he's always said
it with the caveat that you know check
with your doctor first but then says
what have you got to lose if you're
already facing a life-threatening health
emergency you've got in his view and it
is his personal view nothing to lose and
everything to gain and this there is a
case of a state lawmaker in this US
state of Michigan I believe who says she
followed that advice and she believes it
cured her and Donald Trump has talked
extensively about that but again you
heard their doctor Anthony found she's
saying that while there are some
interventions that are now in clinical
trials it could be months before it's
known which one of these are effective
and for I know a little bit from talking
to one of my FDA Food and Drug
Administration contacts that when it
comes to clinical trials what they need
to do is check and see whether or not
there are reproductive side effects and
that's what takes time so to be touting
a therapy which may we do not know have
detrimental effects in terms of human
reproduction and this is something
certainly that the president is gambling
with but he's using his pulpit and we
know that these briefings are widely
watched to tout this and this is one of
the concerns the US president is putting
forward medical advice without the
proper background in order to do so it's
good Friday let's be nice okay let's be
real nice yeah please go ahead thanks
mr. president can you clarify a little
bit of what the u.s. offer to Mexico in
order to agree that oil deal and then
also go into detail about what you spoke
about on oil with persons
all of the OPEC nations met and others
and they're all agreeing to cut back
because there's a tremendous flood we
don't even we're filling up our
strategic reserves we don't even have
room to store it in fact they're using
ships to store oil it's there's never
been anything like this it was being
over produced to start off with and then
you had the virus and that took off 40
percent right there so we have there's a
glut of oil like nobody's ever seen
before it's good in many ways and
depending on where you are who you are
it's bad we have a tremendous energy
business with hundreds of thousands of
jobs we're doing great number one in the
world so they all got together and they
said we're going to cut it because we
have to get rid of this tremendous
supply now the good news is gasoline
prices I'm seeing 90 cents 85 cents in
different parts of the country a gallon
nobody's ever seen that I guess you have
to go back to the 1950s for that the big
large dollar bills remember you don't
remember you're too young but the fact
that you have to go back a long ways to
see it so there's some good the airlines
are trying to come back having low fuel
costs is good for them are the reasons
steel manufacturing but a lot of the
steel goes to building and what we do
for the oil and engineering firms so you
know that's a that's a double-edged
sword but it's it's we want to keep our
energy we want to remain independent we
will remain independent I think
regardless but we want to get rid of
this tremendous overflow there's no
place to even store it so the OPEC
nations met they've been meeting and you
know I've hated OPEC over the years
absolutely hated them but obviously it
broke down and we potentially have years
worth of supply a long time before it
ever can catch up even if they do reduce
it and they agreed but Mexico didn't
agree it was one of the few countries
that didn't agree the so Peck plus the
OPEC plus countries outside you
understand it
yeah and Mexico didn't agree and I
understand the president very well he
has a level when he came in and he
wanted to keep it at that level oil is
important for Mexico the problem is and
I explained it very strongly you know
you're gonna be selling it for $5 or $10
a barrel so in the
it's bad but he did have some political
difficulty with it frankly and I
understand that too and it's a small
amount for us it's a large amount for
Mexico but it's a very small amount for
the United States being the biggest
producer so I agreed to pick up some of
the slack so he was going to reduce it
by a hundred thousand barrels reduces
output by a hundred thousand barrels and
I was going to pick up the slack and
they would make it up to us at a later
date they would make up what we're doing
at a later date it could be in a
different form and I don't know whether
or not that's going to be from Mexico
was acceptable I don't know whether or
not that's going to be acceptable to the
other oil-producing nations we'll find
out but it's something that would
certainly be acceptable to me to get it
over the back so Mexico is going to
reduce by a hundred thousand barrels and
that would mean that they're 250 to 300
barrels short we'd make up the
difference they would reimburse us at a
later date okay you mean maybe a
difference by US production by cutting
some US production now the u.s.
production has already been cut because
we're a market driven economy and and
oil is very market driven they've been
cutting oil all over the place we're
cutting it back and what does it mean
really it means we haven't in the ground
we can use it now we have a lot of we
have a lot of ground with a lot of oil
in it when I think we're number one in
that - we're probably number one
especially with Anwar as you know I got
an whare approved in Alaska that's one
of the biggest fights anywhere in the
world so when you add it all up I think
we're probably number one even in what
we have under we're very lucky we were
we grew up in a land that was rich in a
lot of ways but it's also rich because
it has a lot of oil underneath oil and
gas and as you know natural gas LNG is
all over the country now at a very low
price and our carbon our our atmosphere
our the level of environmental
cleanliness is that its all-time best
right now all-time best because we are
using a lot of natural gas but we have
many forms of energy including some of
the newer forms that people want to see
us go to we have a lot of different
forms of energy
number one in the world we want to keep
it that way so we're helping Mexico out
we will be reimbursed in a forum
sometime in the future this rather than
I'll ask you about the new federal
projections in a moment but first today
you tweeted the invisible enemy will
soon be in full retreat given its
invisible without widespread testing how
would you know well I think that we're
going to have it in retrieved with it
will it be today no tomorrow no but it
will be at a certain point in the
not-too-distant future it will be gun
testing specifically Michael oh no no
because people aren't going to go to the
hospital people aren't going to get sick
you're gonna know that with that but
we're going to do very substantial
testing we're doing more testing right
now than any other country in the world
by far
I'll have the professional answer it
Deborah
perhaps you could come up we are doing
tremendous testing but you'll know
you're gonna know before anybody because
you're gonna see nobody's getting sick
anymore it will be gone and it won't be
that much longer go ahead ask about the
projections out there thanks mr.
president
Thank You mr. president so the testing I
want to re-emphasize about what kind of
testing we're talking about this is RN a
diagnostic testing that is the platform
that was built to respond to this
epidemic it is the same platform that we
utilize for HIV viral loads and so many
HIV clients have also given up their
space on the machines to have these
tests run for all of Americans this
assay is complicated it's not like an
assay that you have for your other
diseases your strep test or other
diseases like that this is a very
complicated assay that requires I'm a
lot of technical oversight and it's part
of the reason why not all a hundred
percent our machines are running at full
capacity but we had great discussion
with a lab directors about that every
day more are brought online and so but I
think we have to create expectations of
what the daily test rates will be last
year we probably did three million HIV
viral loads or four million HIV viral
loads as a country we've done over to
almost 2.2 million in four weeks so this
is unprecedented in what we
have to do I think that's why we're
working very hard for two pieces and I
want to make sure that people understand
testing is just part of our strategy the
other part of the strategy has to be
this syndromic and influenza like
illness where there's an alert to an
illness and so that we're surveying
where we know the most vulnerable cases
have appeared and a great call that I
had with the mayor's and with on the
health officials yesterday and mayor's
today a lot of the rural areas their
primary and as it was in Washington in
California was it the nursing homes so
the the issue is to build a testing
strategy that speaks to our strengths of
laser focusing a strategic approach to
testing when we know what our volumes
are and they increase every day but we
have to be realistic about what the
volumes will be a week two weeks three
weeks from now and combine that with
strategic surveillance so that we're
testing symptomatic people and their
contacts very quickly to go back to
contact tracing utilizing our complete
strategy and I think we're very much
interested in it's why the president
three weeks ago really put us on getting
an antibody test and I think I called
from the podium for our University
colleagues and unit and hospitals to
begin analyze abased test because that's
a blood draw but we really wanted a
finger prick to make it easy and
deployable that's what's being worked on
now of course we don't want to promise
until we have it because I think we
deserve that the American people deserve
that to have a test that is efficient to
let people know who's been positive for
immunity that's critical to
epidemiologists and public health
officials to know what the penetrance of
a virus was into a community when all
you're seeing are the serious cases and
testing the most symptomatic and so
that's a question that we still have is
this the tip of the iceberg or is this
half the iceberg or three-quarters of
the iceberg what we have seen to date
and we have I just want to complete the
thought by saying in the areas where we
had an outbreak these large metros
Louisiana Denver Detroit Chicago New
York
New Jersey but per capita we've done
more tests than any other place in the
world that was intentional we focused
the tests where with a need was the
greatest and the burden of disease the
greatest and now we're trying to really
see how strategically that very valuable
resource can be utilized around the
countries to create a mosaic of testing
combined with surveillance let's ask
about the new federal projections
there's new reporting today the new
federal projections suggest let me ask
you
helicam about the new federal
projections that suggest lifting the
30-day shelter-in-place orders would
lead to a spike in infections have you
seen those new projections from your
Department of Homeland Security and HHS
when did they say this would take place
where these know that it would take
place if the 30-day shelter in place
were to be removed they're three they
haven't seen it I guess you're seeing
they were I guess they leaked it to NBC
they did weakens assets being or nobody
seen it and they're the ones are doing
so ministration to assets from the HHS
and DOJ
first of all Peter I haven't seen that
so I can't quote on that that's okay I
still haven't seen I've been here all
day what I think that they're talking
about is that whenever you pull back you
would expect that you might start seeing
cases and what we've been talking about
what dr. Burks has just mentioned is
that when you see that that's where you
want your resources to be able to very
efficiently in real time identify
isolate and contact trace so don't let
anyone get any false ideas that when we
decide at a proper time when we're gonna
be relaxing some of the restrictions
there's no doubt you're gonna see cases
I would be so surprised if we did not
see cases the question is how you
respond to them I think that's what they
were referring to
president should Americans have to
decide between staying healthy and going
back to work look I think we're going to
do both we're gonna go back to work and
we're gonna stay healthy and staying
healthy is also a proportion if you look
at what we're doing we're looking at a
date we hope we're going to be able to
fulfill a certain date but we're not
doing anything until we know that this
country is going to be healthy we don't
want to go back and start doing it over
again even though it would be in a
smaller scale
yeah Jeff go ahead follow up question
the President of Mexico said that you
had agreed that the US would cut
production by 250,000 barrels per day is
that what you agreed to yes we would
which we've already done by the way but
we would agree to a reduction cut they
would agree to do something to
compensate us in the future don't you
make any assurances to Saudi Arabia that
you the United States would not bail out
oil drillers here we didn't discuss that
with Saudi Arabia we just discussed the
numbers that we discussed who's
approached and who's not and pretty much
everybody is in favor of it because
they're getting clobbered they're all
getting clobbered all of those countries
are having problems if you look at Saudi
Arabia that's their source of income
primary source of income by far so they
want to do it Russia wants to do it the
OPEC nations want to do it they all want
to do it so we'll see what happens
there's a difference between wanting to
do it and doing it yeah go ahead oh yeah
that is where your administration has
placed a 15 million dollar bounty on
Venezuela's nicolas maduro and we have
news this morning that President Xi is
talking with Nicolas Maduro
expressing his financial support for
Maduro so two questions one have you
discussed with dr. sheet or President Xi
you're the US policy on Maduro and who
are what is how does it affect us policy
we will not be happy if that takes place
I have not spoken to President Xi of
China about Venezuela about that aspect
of Venezuela but if that took place we
will not be happy ok I will know I'm
concerned about everything that's why I
don't sleep a lot I get myself concerned
about everything but I would not be
happy about that go ahead president
getting back to Peter's question a
variation of that question you're
doctors who are gathered here seem to be
in doubt as to whether or not the
country could reopen on May the 1st if
they come to you before May the 1st and
say the country is not ready are huge
parts of the country are not ready to
reopen on May the 1st will you listen to
them and listen to them about everything
I think they're actually surprised I
have great respect for these people all
of them instead of working with us I
have great respect for this group in
fact I told Tony Faraci
I said why don't you move to New York
run against AOC you will win easily so
he decided that he's not going to do
that ok I kid by the way they you know
that so some of your allies have been
bashing these doctors would you tell
them to cut it out I can only say this I
have tremendous respect for these people
and we've done very well and when you
look at us compared to others we're a
big nation when you look at us compared
to others when you see how we've taken
testing from a broken system that I
inherited to having the best tests that
anyone's made anywhere in the world and
other countries are calling us wanting
to use our technology I have great
respect for these people come back she's
never saying bad about this
if they come back to you service age
before May the first we can't open on
May the first do you listen I will
certainly listen I will certainly let's
take outside you remember there's I know
I understand the other side of the
argument very well because I look at
both sides of an argument I will listen
to them very carefully though please go
ahead Thank You mr. president you may
have seen this but JP Morgan came out
with a forecast about GDP growth in the
second quarter the sank a 40 percent
decline in the second quarter of this
year do your economic advisors share
that view um I think my economic
advisors are interested in the third
quarter and really the fourth quarter
and I think we have a chance to do
record fourth quarter numbers because
there's a tremendous pent up demand and
you see it this week I mean what reason
would there be other than faith in us
and in this country faith in this group
and me and your vice president and
everybody governor's perhaps you can add
them into it also what reason would that
be for in a shortened week four days
instead of five to have the biggest
stock market gain in over 50 years so I
think that you know to me there's a sign
hey look with all we've been down I mean
we've we've never been hit I don't know
has this country ever been hit like this
probably not 1917 but that was different
and it was a different time and frankly
Europe took the brunt of it we didn't
but it was a terrible time also but
probably never been hit like this right
somebody was saying in fact I was
speaking with Governor Cuomo about it
because we were in New York City a place
we loved New York State with the World
Trade Center and that was approximately
3,000 people well we've doubled that in
this same area we've doubled that more
than doubling substantially more and
it's obviously going you know we had our
highest number yesterday in the day
before
okay with all of this news what would
lead you to believe that we're gonna
have the best stock market week
shortened wig in 50 years almost broke
the all-time record you know that is
that's a pent-up two men now that's my
opinion the other thing is we're doing
tremendous stimulus plans and just
would you read it you know this back and
forth but we are getting along with the
Democrats they want to see something
happen we have to help our workers we
have to help our small businesses we
have to help we have to help our
restaurants I think deductibility will
be great for entertainment restaurants
all of that look I think with the
stimulus with the people with what we've
got going with all of the things whether
it be meeting with the airline's over
the weekend we have a great plan for the
airlines we kind of keep the airlines
going you know it's never been a great
business but it's a very vital business
for the country we're gonna be meeting
with Boeing we're gonna be meeting with
a lot of companies that are great
companies and we're great companies a
short while ago I mean we can't let
anything happen to Boeing it's you know
got so much potential you talk about
potential can anything have more
potential than that so we have a lot of
very exciting things taking place we
have tremendous plans we have tremendous
stimulus and I think we have a chance to
do really well so this quarter is in the
quarter I'm looking at the third quarter
we start to think about it and I think
fourth quarter is going to be at a level
that maybe we haven't seen before I
think our country with the stimulus with
all that we've been through we've
learned a lot don't forget we've learned
about pandemics and epidemics we've
learned a tremendous amount and with all
that we've learned as an example we're
making ventilators we have thousands of
them being delivered in the very near
future we have countries calling us can
we have ventilators that would have been
an unthinkable call I'd be I wouldn't
know what to say they have people dying
but we needed them for ourselves we have
plenty before the surge in New York they
need far fewer hospital rooms or far
fewer hospital beds in particular than
we thought and I have to say dr. Brooks
told me that four weeks ago six weeks
here remember you said that number is
too high we don't need that money and
based on what she said and others we did
what we had to do we actually gave the
maximum we built Javits we sent the ship
in we then made the ship kovat because
you know
a lot of people on the roads you didn't
have the accidents that we thought other
unrelated X and there's nobody driving
you know normally have a lot of car
accidents you have a lot of motorcycle
accidents you have people going to the
house we didn't have that we had almost
none of it so a lot of things have
happened I think we have a chance to be
stronger than before I really do
I think the stimulus is very important
what we're doing I think it's very very
important please go ahead and press
advance give up credit and did as well
many American individuals families have
had to tap their credit cards during
this period and businesses have had to
draw down their credit lines are you
concerned mr. president that that may
hobble the US economy all of that debt
number one and number two would you
suggest to credit card companies to
reduce their fees during this time
what's something that we've already
suggested we're talking to them business
interruption insurance I'd like to see
these insurance companies you know you
have people that have paid when I was in
private I had business interruption when
my business was interrupted through a
hurricane or whatever it may be I have
business where I had it I didn't always
have it sometimes I had it sometimes I
have a lot of different companies but if
I had it I'd expect to be paid you have
people I speak mostly to the restaurant
tours where they have a restaurant
they've been paying for 25 30 35 years
business interruption they've never
needed it all of a sudden they need it
and I'm very good at reading language I
did very well in these subjects okay and
I don't see the word pandemic mentioned
now some cases it is it's an exclusion
but in a lot of cases I don't see it I
don't see reference and they don't want
to pay up I would like to see the
insurance companies pay if they need to
pay if it's fair and they know what's
fair and I know what's fair I can tell
you very quickly but business
interruption insurance that's getting a
lot of money to a lot of people and
they've been paying for years you know
sometimes they just started paying but
you have people that have never asked
for business interruption insurance and
they've been paying a lot of money for a
lot of years for the privilege of having
it and then when they finally need it
the insurance company says we're not
going
give it we can't let that happen oh
that's us president Donald Trump Oh
giving his daily briefing to the
assembled press there at the White House
let's bring in Kimberly how could
Kimberly should Americans decide should
they stay healthy or go back to work the
president was asked both he said when
the time is right they will stay healthy
and they will go back to work yeah a
little bit of a contradiction there from
the US president because on the one hand
he said that he would listen to public
health officials as we know these
national guidelines until April 30th in
the United States 98% of Americans
affected by them for the most part
staying home it's had a devastating
impact obliterated the US economy and so
the question becomes you know May 1st
the day after what is your advice to
Americans and will you listen to public
health officials if they say look it you
need to extend these guidelines the US
president for now saying yes that he
would listen to those but guidelines but
at the same time we've had even him
tweeting as early as this morning that
we know that there have been plans in
the works for the better part of a week
and from the administration officials
behind the scenes working on a plan to
reopen the aspects of the US economy get
Americans back to work sometime in the
middle of May perhaps even earlier and
you did hear one of the questions coming
up in that briefing one of those
follow-up questions is from one of the
reporters saying but how can this happen
if there is no national testing plan in
place and there seem to be a bit of a
dodging of that question only sort of an
answer from the public health officials
that that is part of the strategy but
that they are still building it so as
you can see in terms of Americans going
back to work and knowing whether or not
they can do that and still remain
healthy
the answer still remains very much in
question it doesn't appear that there is
a definitive answer coming from those
public health officials right and
there's also this date of May the first
mentioned in one of the questions wasn't
there saying that if the doctors came
back to the president and said look you
can't reopen now would he listen and he
said he said he would but he also knows
the other side of the argument was
should I by which I presume he meant the
economy
yeah absolutely that's definitely what
he means and the other question that the
president was asked about is this
invisible enemy that he constantly talks
about that he's a wartime president and
he has retreated in very recently that
it will be in retreat retreat soon that
soon it will be gone you know the
president doubled down on that and it is
certainly again one of his sort of over
optimistic projections given the fact
that he was standing in the same room as
public health officials who say there is
reason to be optimistic but this is not
the time to be getting overexcited about
removing any of these restrictions
because we know that there are other
areas where there are encouraging signs
but still things are very dire we are
talking about you know more than 10,000
tens of thousands of Americans who have
died and hundreds of thousands of
Americans who have been infected then
the United States has hardly turned the
corner that's the message for these
public health officials even as the US
president continues to project optimism
and he's defended this all the way long
saying that he has to be the country's
cheerleader in dark times dark economic
times in times of anxiety that's what
he's continuing to do sending once again
these contradictory contradictory mixed
messages all right can't believe
appreciate that that's can be Huck Adair
Washington DC